well welcome to another edition of down
the middle uh i i'm really excited to
continue on this path of
educating investors about passive
investing which is what most of the
people who are watching
this do this is a youtube channel that's
how how millennials have learned to
invest
joining me today is vincent de la
he is the global macro strategist at
stonex every week he writes reports that
guide
his company's investors including big
pension funds um and other institutions
if you name the financial publication
whether it be the financial times barons
the wall street journal he's in it he's
been he's been quoted in it he is
considered to be one of the the world's
preeminent uh experts in how passive
investing works or how the exchange
traded fund
world works that where we most of us
invest
but i want to get into a little bit of
his background first um
where did you grow up
who were your who are your biggest who
are the biggest influencers in your life
um because you're clearly coming to us
today from california not paris
yes
oh thank you daniel it's a pleasure to
be here uh pleasure to engage with your
audience i love the work that you do so
i think thanks for having me
[Applause]
yes so i grew up in a small town in
burgundy which is a lovely one country
in france um
and yeah markets was not necessarily
where where i thought life would lead me
um
you know i kind of followed a very uh
traditional path for french
students middle class students you know
you take an exam you go to a hard school
and then you train to become a public
servant because this is the most
glorious path
uh one can one can follow in france and
uh
at the time i did it without much much
thinking i mean this is just what you do
i had always had a an interest oddly
enough starting with coins uh one of the
reasons why i hate the euro is because i
love the uh
i love like as a kid i collected coins
from from every country i just love the
the image and i you know it made me
curious about history like why is this
person on this note and i actually
thought it was really cool and of course
for me 2002 was it was a tragedy when
that you know we replaced all these
beautiful european coins that has so
much meaning with these ugly notes you
know we couldn't even agree on what we
would put on the notes that's how
dysfunctional the eu is the french
correctly said we should put french
grain men on it because you know we have
so many of them but turns out
the other 16 members of the eurozone
also thought that they had a history
that was worth telling so anyway we
could not agree on anything and then we
just put bridges on there which is kind
of see but well long story short uh
i studied uh
i studied in a in a in a sport in paris
uh
with some very famous uh politicians as
professors and and the more when the
more
scared i was
i thought about my destiny like oh this
is going to be what i do for the rest of
my life and i i got lucky i got a
scholarship to study
in the us got my master's degree in new
york
and then this was just before the
financial crisis which meant if you
could open an excel spreadsheet back in
2006 you could call yourself a hedge
fund analyst
uh
so i was hired by a small research firm
out of sausalito
and of all things my first job was to
track money flows especially into bts
and mutual funds and that really
i think that really framed my
understanding of markets not so much as
kind of what i later on with the cfa has
been discounted cash flow analysis and
all of that stuff but like realizing
that anything at any point in time
um
the price of a stock is a function of
the supply of money that's going in and
how many shares are being sold i mean i
i like to think of
the the stock market is no different
from
uh the pork belly market right i mean if
you were to analyze the potential market
you look at how many folks they are in
demand for bacon so that's how i think
about the market and i think that's what
it brought me towards that um obsession
with passive and its impact on market
structure so um before we before we go
there i've got a few other questions to
get to know you a little bit better
you're clearly ready to jump into the
markets but we're going to we're going
to take a step back
i'm sorry didn't you have an interesting
professor uh
in paris when you were studying when you
were possibly going to go the path of
working in treasury
well actually i had two interesting
professors two okay let's go
the first one was uh
at the time a very prominent fellow
called dominic's postgana uh
that was before 2011 and before he got
caught in a nasty hotel room in new york
uh
but i mean he as far as i can tell he
was a
he was a good account professor um
very smart very bright person
uh someone
eventually led to his downfall that were
quite obvious already uh in school
uh
but uh he was a he was a good professor
and and then uh one of my first ta in uh
uh constitutional law was a a bright
young man
um
who was destined to a great future
called emmanuel macron he was barely a
few years older than me and he was
already teaching and i mean as far as i
can tell he was uh
you know i mean he was almost our age
right so he was cool too you know he was
just a fun person to hang out and
i mean that's
that but that's the way france works and
it's a very uh
very close circle of powerful people who
kind of go to the same school right uh
africans
you know hang out together and i think
that to some extent explains some of the
the disconnect we're seeing between the
kind of the populist evolved like the
yellow west and
an establishment that is not always in
sync
uh even though as far as i can tell like
you know these people are very competent
and very smart uh but there is a level
of inbreeding that is uh i think
problematic
so um before you
before you were kind of
all the way into your career uh and this
is i i went straight from business
school to wall street so i i didn't i
thought about it but i didn't do it and
you know i don't know if i regret it to
this day or not but you are a charter
charter financial analyst
can you explain what that is because a
lot of a lot of viewers won't know what
it is and can you explain what how you
think it helped you
uh after you got out of business school
because it's it's it's a commitment in
and of itself and in a post-covered
world
we've certainly seen a huge dramatic
decline in the number of of students who
are getting out of business school who
are even studying for the the cfa
yes um
absolutely i mean so the cfa is a
it's a non-profit association that's um
initially it's a trade group you can
think of it started i think out of
boston and new york just analysts kind
of getting together and saying okay well
that you know there was no rule so let's
let's first establish a charter of
conduct to make sure that we behave
ethically and we don't you know uh
recommend stocks that we own or so
there's an ethical aspect to it
and then
there is the exam aspect which which
grew over time i think at the beginning
it was just like a one-hour exam and now
it turned into this
indeed a very big endeavor it's you know
three exams usually over the course of
three years most people fail at this one
level
um
and it's it's a lot of material it
really is and i mean even um
i don't know i i thought of you know i
thought i was smart when i
i did it i thought oh he said no no no
no one no one's tomorrow this is too
much stuff and you have to put the hours
but it's good it gives you a foundation
like for example there was areas where i
was you know econ corn stuff easy but
the accounting for me was like okay you
really need to understand how to read a
financial statement right
this very valuable skill i mean well now
it's everything's passive so you just
need to buy the market hold forever but
assuming uh you know when we come back
to normal capital markets these are
these are very useful skills i would say
um it's a big investments a big
commitment um i would recommend to do it
before you have the family life which is
kind of what i did you know because
otherwise it's going to be very hard you
have to book i would say you know two
hours of your day
for you know a couple months before the
exam and you have a high chance of
failing but
i found it to be a good community i i
teach
i used to teach at the
society back in san francisco
and i think i mean it kind of depends
but
if you are
somewhat young
and you don't necessarily have parents
who were investment bankers or a you
know a a big job uh
maybe uh at the data spend um
then it's a way to kind of differentiate
yourself and also communicate to your
employer that you are willing to put the
hard work um
that you know what you're going to talk
about and i think
i mean there's always a debate like
should i do the mba should i do cfa i
mean i've known great people who've done
both
uh
one thing that i would say in favor of
the cfa is that something can pursue
alongside of your career and the
investment costs wise a lot less a lot
lower
right
and it also kind of
really gives you a feel you know and
if you don't know exactly what it is
that you want to do
this year it's gonna
all right you know if you're able to do
a cfa that means you're ready for it
you're in finance yep so it's funny you
mentioned the choice between the cfa and
the mba i i chose to get my mba in
finance actually my second master's is
from columbia so we have that in common
but when people ask me to look back and
say what was your hardest class i always
say managerial accounting it was it was
a double class i thought it was going to
kill me and yet the skill set that i
walked out with in terms of learning
that accounting is it's carried me
through my career it's so i it resonates
with me when you're like you got to get
those skills down you got to understand
how to read a balance sheet
so accounting also helps us count
and um
if you look back
to just
11 12 years ago
according to state state street uh the
assets under management
in index funds we're just over a
trillion dollars
and we're about to
cross the 10 trillion dollar mark
in
etf passive invested this is
massive massive growth 10x in 12 years
uh
explain explain
the very basic
basic basics and i've asked the same
question of a friend of yours mike mike
green explain the very basics of why
passive
is a misnomer
and why passive is actually active
right um
so
we've passed it i mean you
you know you replace the uh
the role of the phone manager with an
index right i mean that's that's the
idea is instead of
you know giving you money to beat lynch
you're going to buy a phone that shot
the smp 500 index so that really just
changes the level at which a stock
selection decision is made from a you
know a human with these emotions and
qualities and flaws to
um the index comedy i mean for example
take the case of the s p 500 index um
the s p 500 index is not the 500 largest
stocks in the u.s and even if it were by
the way that's already a choice right
you're choosing 500 companies in one
country instead of the potential
universe that you could choose so even
if you were a good index uh
it would already be a choice in the case
of the s p 540 especially active because
you have a whole lot of other criterion
that go into play uh you have
requirements against drought class share
for example that they come up in 2017
which means that most people miss the
rally in the you know the big uh tech
names because they all have this like
structure and they got kicked out of the
index but oddly enough they kept the old
one because no one wants to take out
berkshire google the index so this is an
example like a weird kind of discretion
decision they made or look at what kind
of included tesla i mean they waited way
too long uh
and for reasons that were not so clear
and of course i ended up costing
investors a lot of money because they
missed the big running tesla and then of
course as people knew that tesla had to
be added you know by the time it became
like a 3 400 billion market cap i mean
you called me down on the index right so
then you had all these arbitrages that
started beating up the price of tesla so
if you get the price of tesla i think it
was in
november 2018 the price shoots up before
before it gets included index so that
just means that effectively you are
arbitragers are effectively stealing
money from people that are investing in
next phone so you have all these
discretionary decisions and you have a
lot more also coming with you know what
how do you handle stock speeds mergers
uh how you trade
when you have inflows and outflows all
these things are not part of the
original passive index uh philosophy the
the case that was made by um
uh bogol
and then before before that be a sharp
which is so passive it's kind of like
you know passive netter trades
passive never makes any decision that's
that's the framework the theoretical
framework that academics develops
that
created the basis for the industry as we
know it today but the industry as we
know today is very different from that i
mean you have the ehd front you have the
smart beta uh you have sectors you have
thematic stuff so you can't really say
that passive as a whole
uh is really passive you have a bunch of
active decisions that are made just
people are not aware
um
so uh
in may of 2021
so may earlier 2021 you said for now
money will keep flowing into index funds
uh whether we like it or not
at the same time
bubbles like stars
eventually collapse under their own
gravity
those are those are big words
thank you
yes so um
it's part of the conundrum of being uh
and i i wouldn't necessarily
label myself a critic of passive like i
you know i own um passive phones i even
own target need for that matter and one
of my friends asked me for you know what
should i do well for okay i mean
you know i
tell them well you know buy a total
market from index you know vanguard's
very low fees so i'm not um you know
ideologically against it but at the same
time i think we need to be cognizant of
um
the the macro impacts of what you
described which is going from one
trillion to ten by the way i think it's
more than ten today especially including
the
smas and
the the strategies that replicate uh
passive indexing that that you don't see
that in mutual from gfo so i think right
now i would my estimate is close to 50
of the market uh uh being run of assets
being on my index funds or
strategies that are based off index
funds and then in terms of flows we're
probably looking at more like 90
goes into strategies and in terms of
trading it's probably uh you know 90
training is in some shape or form the
result of passive flows um
so you know i i went on attention and i
forgot to question
um oh yeah you you quoted that it felt
like it's already yes so yes for now
it's going to keep happening it's just
at this point it's just it's a it's a
machine it has its own momentum it's
built in especially with the new uh the
dol guidance on 401ks that basically
puts people by default into target date
forms that then get allocated to the
next one so basically every time the
americans get paid there's a portion of
a paycheck uh you know anywhere between
five and ten percent that goes in a
retirement account called 401k and then
unless they make an active decision not
to go with it that gets invested into a
target date funds uh but which
ultimately gets
all the way down to an index fund so
a moment like we are today when wages
are soaring by twenty percent over year
over year the amount of money is
gargantuar and it just it will keep
going for sure uh
but at some point i mean the way i like
to think about it is the this concept of
the laffer curve which is you know
something that the reagan economists
like in the 80s the view is like well
you know if you keep if you raise taxes
initially raises revenues for the
government but then if you have 100 tax
rate obviously nobody works uh so
revenues fall to zero so at some point
there must be some sort of infection
point um
same thing is true passive a little bit
of passive in the way that john vogel
thought about it maybe 10 20 yes markets
are still gonna work price discovery is
still going to happen the passive sector
is still going to be
free riding the work of active investors
but when passive becomes dominant
you know instead of the if you consider
the dog wagging the tail it's more the
tail wagging the dog right
and if you get theoretically that 100
passive stock market which we may get at
this point nothing could happen right
because uh uh everybody would be an
index fund you couldn't raise capital
they would you know uh no one would
trade with each other even uh so you get
to a point where the market would stop
working um so where is that infection
point is it is it thirty percent passive
forty fifty seventy we're going to find
out i would argue that we are already
seeing signs that um again the the tail
is like in the dark past let's wait for
that let's wait for that let's wait for
that because i promise it's coming i
promise it's coming but i want you to
back up and explain
if you wouldn't mind um
the automation effect of
of of the 401k how it's become in your
words a whale
uh so
and you just mentioned a department of
labor ruling
that has made something that was already
automated even more automated but but if
you can go back and explain how it's a
whale
and why we don't
periodically witness statistical
miracles
perfect so yeah so uh
he said two thousand 20 2015 uh
department of labor guidance on
something called qualified default
investment alternative
and i think the
the issue that we're
trying to solve to their credit i i
don't think there was nefarious intense
there
is the fact that a lot of people even if
they do have a 401k and they contribute
an employer is contributing they're just
not investing the money because they
don't have the knowledge it's stressful
um you know they don't know what to buy
there are too many options so uh the
ebola level say well we're going to put
them by default uh into something that
we think is good for you and that thing
that they think is good for them is the
lowest cost option which means an index
phone and then you know because you need
to match the investment profile of a
strategy with the uh the age and
restaurants uh we're gonna put your
target date from so a target date phone
is a automatically self-rebalancing
uh strategy where you know as you're
young you're going to be maybe 90
equities 10 percent bonds and then as
you age your glide path is going to
reduce the number of equities in your
phone increase the amount of bonds and
cash so that you have more liquidity
less risk as you get older
that is done automatically it's
completely autopilot so the uh
the uh the money is invested in index
funds uh the largest one of them are the
one produced um issued by vanguard i
think there is a the total market total
stock market from index has more than a
trillion in assets a trillion i mean
this is so this is why i called the
whale right i mean this is
this is just um balance i mean he's
going to move the market of course
uh most of the vanguard target date form
have only three holdings uh total market
u.s
uh total market international
stock and then a total total bond market
index uh and and then the only decision
that happens is of course invest the
money right so every month they get the
checks from the 401k and gets rolled
over uh and so that also creates some um
seasonality right based on on how when
people are paid uh and then the other
the other decision is they need to keep
the
relative weights
of their assets in check at all time so
let's say the strategy is going to be 70
stock 30 bonds so when the stock market
goes up
uh you're gonna if you do nothing you're
going to be maybe 80 20. so you have to
buy the underperforming assets so at the
end of the quarter you rebalance
and
you can actually start seeing that in
prices i mean one thing that uh my
friend migraine and i noticed is the the
patterns of of recent market bottoms on
the s p 500 i mean after covida the
bottom was march 23 the third friday of
the last day of the quarter uh after the
the power bear market um you know the
christmas massacre right so it was on
december 24 i think because the the
friday
there was a holiday but basically it was
the same the third friday the fourth
month and when we had the the volume
in 2018
uh again it was until the 23rd on the
third friday of the month so you have
three
market bottoms basically on the same
date and you got what is the statistical
probability that this happens
the more likely explanation is that in
both cases stocks were down 20 or more
uh and most of these target date forms
were massively underweight stocks
because they had to go back right so if
you were 80 80 20 and the stocks have
dropped like almost 30 percent during
kobe you know your allocation look more
like um you know a 60 40 by then so you
had to think about a trillion dollar
fund right that whale i mean so it has
to go back increase by 20 just on that
phone you get a 200 billion inflow into
the market and of course that's gonna
that's gonna lift everything up i mean
there's nobody can just has like 200
billion dollar to sale at any point in
time yeah until until you and mike
taught me about this i really did think
it was just jay powell but but he just
had really good timing
but the one that was interesting was the
powell pivot wasn't until
january 4th
of 2019 and yet to your point
the stock market had already started to
recover before powell made that speech
and to me that that is the one that is
the most indicative of the power of this
rebalancing
and how it manifested in the markets
before he got up on stage and said i
apologize for my younger days and saying
qe was bad
um let's shift gears for a little bit um
you recently wrote something that i
found to be
kind of blasphemous i said wow wow he
put that in writing
you said esg is a fairy tale
uh i mean there's probably a lot of
there may be some people who just turned
this interview off bye thank you see you
um explain explain what that means
environmental social and governance
more than 3 000 signatories to the
united nations principles for investment
manage more than a hundred trillion
dollars
this we're not talking about you know
pennies here
yes no it
it it's uh
it's it's huge and it's going very fast
there's uh on average this year uh two
and a half new esg etfs have been
launched every day every day
every day yes um it really makes you
wonder you know how many how many do we
need i mean if we keep going at this
space very soon we'll have more esg
phones and we have stocks to select from
um
and um
no i'm listen i
i have nothing but good good good
feelings with the esg movement i mean he
was born in the in the early 90s people
wanted to use the power of their dollars
in order to create change and invest in
virtuous companies and try to develop
their own uh their own rating and
basically an alternative um an
alternative way of investing that's not
based purely on profitability but also
on environmental and social impact so
there's nothing wrong with that idea uh
the fairy tale to me comes when we tell
people that um they will also beat the
market uh which is something that uh
larry think and obviously blackrock
benefits a lot i mean blackrock has been
the forefront of
a lot of these esg launches and and and
now we have this varied tale where's
that oh
do well by doing good not only by
investing in these companies you will
you know help solve climate change which
i mean that should be another
conversation whether you actually
accomplish it's subjective or you know
my view is knowing it's not very clear
to me how giving more money to microsoft
helps up my climate change but um
um nonetheless even let's take that on
face value that you know you are you
know affecting the world in a positive
way and also you would actually see your
results and that claim really is based
on
on the the rally that we saw in esg
firms have actually beaten the market in
2020 uh
and in large part i would say it's
purely coincidental is because esg funds
tend to be overweight big tech because
big tech has very little environment
back and lower social issues because
well there are fewer employees and
they're well paid right so it's it's
easier to you know have good relation
with your workers if you're you know
microsoft and walmart so they were just
they just happened to be at the right
place at the right time but then that
led to all these claims that oh if you
just keep buying hd phones you will keep
beating the market which is actually the
exact opposite of how it should work
even philosophically i mean let's
remember that the idea with esg is you
know you're going to pay more to invest
in virtuous companies and then you're
going to exclude sinful
portfolios so your return should go down
and that's the entire idea you're going
to change capital allocation at a cost
of investor base in order to affect
positive exchange that is the right
pitch
but by telling people that they can have
their cake and add it we're really just
telling them a fairy tale and really the
only people who benefit from this other
people selling uh esg phone or hd index
which i would say
now has become kind of the goal of the
issue industry it's just a mechanism to
create fees
well so and and plus
i mean
esg is one of the first
kind of investing philosophies that has
been born into
a world in which passive was dominant
and so um
you say that relying on passive fund
managers index providers and proxy
managers to make capitalism
um
more
to make it capitalism a moral gain is
like having an arsonist run the fire
department
i mean
can you explain that that very uh
pointed
shall we say yes point point i think i
think that the concept of passive esg is
an oxymoron it's a contradiction in
terms um so again let's go back to esg
the way it was designed by you know the
the
the in the early 90s by people who
really had um you know
goals to impact change the idea was
inherently active is i'm gonna select
the virtuous companies
uh
i'm gonna go through you know the
financial statement i'm gonna analyze
them and also i will engage with them in
order to to uh
to make them behave better and we can
think of uh engine number one and exxon
like some of these guys activists that
make sure that they do what what we
expected uh what we expect them to do
and punish them what we
punish when they don't do it um
tell the media about bad practices and
so forth it's an inherently active game
now however this has been hijacked by
a big uh etf providers
uh
and index phones it's like well no no
we're not gonna do anything we're just
gonna come up with a list every quarter
whatever and according to a methodology
that is very hard to audit that is uh
very
subjective in many ways that leaves many
issues out of the table including the
issues of whether companies pay taxes or
not for example which to me is a big one
and when you care about the world uh you
know paying your taxes it's kind of your
first duty as a as a as a corporate
citizen so we you know we're gonna we're
gonna do that we're gonna package it and
then all you have to do uh is by is by
my etf and and we'll give you like a
little batch of honor like you know
when the teacher gives the kids like a
little star oh you're a little
participation trophy no you're like
you're like an esg investor thank you
for making the world a better place
i mean
again these are people
and i'm not saying this as as negative
i'm just pointing out a contradiction in
terms uh the way the big you know the
vanguard the blackrock the state street
rules to where they are is by automating
and getting rid of the active level of
investing by you know having no research
uh reducing trading not engaging with
companies just blindly following an
index so the notion that somehow the
same three companies will be able to
reorient capitalism in an ethical way
it's probably the hardest task at hand
right i mean you have to define the
world you want to achieve you have to
think of how you're going to achieve
them uh you have to select the companies
you have to engage the company the view
that we can just do that with this
magical list which by the way comes from
a very oligo oligopolistic industry i
mean you basically have next providers
uh stanford the dow jones and snp and
then moody's uh answer msci
who basically have gobbled everybody
around them and they are run i mean they
private corporation they are run for the
the benefits that the fiduciary to
shareholder to maximize profit these
these companies do not have a
responsibility to solve climate change
or address the gender gap or close the
racial gap in america i mean they are
here to create in that indices where
these indices goes money and they get a
little cut on that and the more money
they get the richer they get that is
what they should be doing expecting that
this is somehow going to change the
world is illusionary
so let me just get this straight you've
got an oligopoly of
of
platforms
you've got an oligopoly of index
providers
and they're feeding an oligopoly that is
mostly based in silicon valley
that are already the largest players in
the other index funds
correct so you gotta get oligopoly that
she's an oligopoly great okay this is
very american
yes
and also i think race is an important
question uh
is
you know
what do we think is the most severe
threat facing you know the most silly
dysfunction of capitalism today uh
and i'm not minimizing the issues of
environment and and social justice i
think they are here i'm not a
denier staff
or is it the excessive concentration of
industry in a few hands i don't know
which one is the more important but
i think the the concentration problem is
quite serious
and i am certain that the ehg movement
is making that a lot worse i mean again
if you look at the top holdings of most
csgts first of all it's virtually
indistinguishable from basic index form
and the reason it is that way
is the the closet indexing argument
right no one wants to underperform so
that you know if you want to run it
successfully like these strategies you
you know you you track secretly track
the index you do all this stuff but at
the end of the day you end up with the
same portfolio the only difference is
even more skewed towards big tech so the
biggest holdings are gonna be microsoft
is always the whole time favorite apple
is very big there
facebook some some companies view it as
esg some don't uh amazon same thing a
little worse but in general there's a
big overweight in big tech and and big
and i mean
just ask yourselves like
in 2021 america
do we need more money go to big tech and
big farmer like is this is this solving
the world's problem like
um is it you know by throwing an extra
trillion at defend
how how is this making the world a
better place
well it's not if you go down any street
in san francisco or new york and you see
all the small businesses that are no
longer with us
in the soul of the country but that's a
different subject
so you
one of the subjects that you touch on
is the role of systemic strategies in
influencing
market outcomes
one area of focus that you've
highlighted is and this is going to be
an editing for god knows how long weeks
and weeks maybe months and months who
knows but today as we're talking um you
you've highlighted option the option
expiry which happens to be today uh
how do you think these influence uh
these events if you will influence the
markets
um well we've seen it
theoretically it should not right i mean
you should have this kind of perfectly
efficient market where you know
demand and supply like balance each
other and yeah but i mean clearly it's
not the case i mean i i gave the example
of the the market bottoming four times
on the same date uh so there's a the
target date from channel which is what
we discussed for the rebalancing like
buying buying the asset that goes down
at the end of the quarter
and then you have the the option channel
which is slightly different but
certainly we've seen a lot of that which
um as a result of this kind of um the
stimulus and the population of apps like
robinhood
uh the rise of uh
reddit uh
and then
retail investors kind of getting
together which which is all great by the
way and i'm very unfair of it but part
of the
part of the issue with the with this
rise of um
retail traders
is that they they tend to they have a
lot of money uh and they tend to buy
very leveraged instruments uh short-term
call options on the names you like so
it's the mean stock it's the tesla the
yaya and that that's just to sort the
new source of flow that was not there
before now the people who sell these
options to them uh which has
market maker and and market makers and
worker dealers need to hedge right
because if you sell an option obviously
you know if you sell if you sell a call
uh you know if the stock goes up well
you're gonna be on the hook to find the
stock right so
that creates a problem for them because
they have always hatching flow that they
need to uh
uh
to maintain at all times to keep their
book the the risk
[Music]
their wrist budget
on track
uh
and that means that yes sometimes you
get squeezes
uh completely irrational
uh
spikes and prices that have nothing to
do with from them at all but everything
to do with positioning and can be gained
i mean that was the whole idea between
gamestop
and you know i'm not again i'm not
native on this side i say you know god
bless them i mean it's a game and and
you play by the rules of the game and
then sometimes it's good that a little
guy wins the game against the big guys
it's a david goliath aspect to this
that's quite pleasant to watch if you're
not on the wrong side of it
but yes it contributes to making the
market less and less about fundamentals
and more and more about flows demand and
positioning and over time if you think
that i cannot do that the role of
capital markets is capital allocation
and that is actually very important
price discovery this is what ultimately
makes the economy work this is one of
the reason why the soviet economy
collapsed it's not because their planets
were not smart enough it's because they
had a centralized system uh where
information would not i mean that's what
price is price is in
a signal every every price means some
should mean something about reality if
price mean nothing about reality just
means oh we have these gamma squeeze and
we need to cover and the stock goes up
by a thousand percent then the entire
system i think all the time becomes
inefficient and risks collapsing
well it's good that the fed is the
federal reserve is not very soviet-esque
and that they've really preserved price
discovery i'm being really sarcastic
because fed policy has
i think amplified if you will
indexing amplified the push to passive
because people know that they only have
to be exposed to the market they don't
even know need to know what they're in
because they know that the fed's got
their back so monetary policy has just
been just it's like throwing
gasoline on the fire
right right uh
and and this these two phenomenons feed
of each other and you know this debate
on twitter and a lot of people are like
oh i guess you know no it's it's the fed
stupid and you know it's kiwi money
printer goes bro yeah yeah that's my
weekly i just wrote that it's the fed
stupid anyways go ahead
i mean and to me it it it is both like
it is the the situation the the bubble
situation that we have today is the
product of this
feedback loop
between easy monetary policy
uh price intensity buying by many
central banks not just not just the fed
but abroad as well and um the rise of
the rise of passage that contributes
creating this mentality that yes the
name of the games you just want to get
exposure right and since stock prices
only go up because the fed is gonna bait
out the market every time there's a
correction uh really you know all you
have to do is just you know uh buy an
index firm and and and not worry about
anything else and
again i mean
if we think that the fed's mandate
you know also includes financial
stability which i think it should
uh
you know
over time i think that there's a
contradiction between
what seems to be the objective of
constantly rising stock prices which
uh certainly is what we've achieved
and financial stability over the long
term
so um
you know obviously 2017
marked
peak global quantitative easing so i
mean globally i think i always like to
say qe is global and fungible
it doesn't matter where the liquidity is
coming from it just matters that the
liquidity is flowing
and 2018 and 17 marked that peak
without retail investors by the way no
retail participation and then we turn
the corner to 2018 and the liquidity
starts to come off
so how do you feel
uh
again given the fact that
the that target date funds are a force
in and of themselves regardless of the
fed beginning to taper but but how do
you factor into your thinking
the fact that the liquidity is going to
slowly come off
in terms of the flows into the market on
the part of the fed if they stick with
it who knows
right um
i'm a little bit worried uh about 2022
uh
because we have
several
possible squeezes on market liquidity so
one of them is you mentioned that the
the taper
uh
where you know we're gonna go from 120
billion a month to zero in in six months
uh
now that could be upset uh to some
extent by like we abroad i don't think
the european central bank is gonna stop
uh maybe actually increase
uh but in general i mean the fed again
and we're talking like
reducing the pace of acceleration i mean
of course yes
yeah but at
always matter so yes yes it is it's kind
of secondary argument i mean they're
still buying just less fast and also
they're reinvesting so it's not the
actual paper we had after 2015 when the
balance sheet actually shrank i mean no
one's talking about that yet which is
increasing at a slower pace but yes the
market has been used if you will of
getting 120 billion and that's that
number is going to go down
um
the other uh source of liquidity that i
think is uh
going away is coming from the treasury
general account so when when when the us
government uh
uh raises cash uh
for various spending income programs you
can't spend it right away right it's
hard to spend you know even for for dc
position you can't spend two three in a
day right so you park that money uh so
that the us government is basically
checking your camera fed right but then
you trade in your account and you park
that money and then that money can be
lent via the repo market so that creates
a lot of equity so that tga
was very full uh because we had so much
insurance uh in 2020 and not much
spending and then the government been
kind of drawing that down over time so
that means it's going to have to
replenish it how do you finish it where
you should get uh so you you know you
give basically a piece of paper for
people's money so that sucks money out
of the system and then you have to put
it back on the cash account so that
sucks money on the system that could
happen at the same time as the fed is
tightening and there's an aspect i think
there's a squeeze that comes from from
high commodity prices uh remember that
commodities need to be financed right i
mean if you um if you're an all-importer
well you need to buy that in advance you
need to book the ship uh you need to pay
the producer in advance the producer
needs to have this production so all of
that
demand is a function of the price of
rules so if all is that you know 20
bucks or minus 40 the way it was
that cost the cost of like financing you
know two months of old production is
very low at 80 bucks a lot higher and
it's not just oil it's called yadda
yadda so you see more money being tied
into commodities which is something that
you sometimes see the feds say that uh
that rarely explains that there is a
tightening aspect that comes from higher
commodity prices it's like a natural
tightening because
more uh you know uh commodities suck
equip your way so you have these three
forces that could certainly be away in
the next six months
um
is it gonna be enough
i thought i mean
i will admit to a mistake one portal i
thought we'd have a correction this
quarter it was my guess i only had a
little bit of weakness for a couple of
days in september but again by two days
standard you know three percent is a
bear market uh
and they right back up because you have
all these other sources of liquidity
against that
uh one is this target date from channel
which is very very important again think
of every american spending five to ten
percent of their paycheck just getting
invested in the market again and again
and incomes are up by 20 year-over-year
i mean it's insane i mean uh the
household wealth has increased by 31
trillion with a c trillion of the t
since the co bit low i mean this is
we made three times more money in the
postcode recovery as we had lost during
the great financial crisis so it's
it's free great financial crisis just
going the other way
700 percent of gdp and you know
when when you compare to
disposable game it's just the numbers
are insane
but go back for a minute to commodities
if you don't mind um
so
how do you think
what is happening right now we're
disaggregating the supply chain
and we're doing it kind of
by force because some some companies
feel that they could never be in that
position again of the just in time
and being you know caught out uh but but
talk about disagree disaggregating the
supply chain and
and not just reopening in the effect
that that has on the flows but also the
potential
as we've heard starting to come out of
europe of of fresh shutdowns
and and and again just explain one more
time how that influences not just
monetary but fiscal policy
right um
so i think what happened uh
supply chain is a uh
almost a giant whack to the global
economy which was this
you know
really carefully optimized system that
works beautifully right it's miraculous
right you order something on amazon
prime and your phone arrives in two
hours i mean wow if you think about if
you think about what goes into this and
you know just i always wonder wow like
the amount of like where does this come
from who put the i mean
it's stunning and i can get it anytime i
want and it's all working seamlessly
well but it is an extremely fragile
system
uh and and kobe was a giant
trying
uh hit to the to that system and some
people have to stop working uh entire
provinces in china were locked down and
then also consumption's pattern shifted
right i mean there's things you couldn't
spend money on
movie theaters uh
going out restaurants
so some of that spending moved to other
things which you know create added
demand uh for some of these things and
there was not the capacity to supply
them was no longer there uh so you know
you started to see that in you know odd
things like the price of lumber and then
it became uh uh used cars because of
memory ships and uh and now you have a
squeeze on on many commodities so
again this is all kind of this
unraveling of the global supply chain uh
and some of these issues i don't i don't
really see them go away that quickly
especially as we are considering new
ways of lockdown in europe uh as we
still have a zero government policy in
china uh the issues of the ports uh in
the u.s this is very serious it's not
getting addressed uh trucker's number
one i think half of truckers are going
to retire the next five years i mean
who's going to replace them um so i
think i think for a long time we've
completely under invested in supply
chain and building resilience in the
system
uh because it was never a problem right
you could always order more from china
and we never had to think about it and
we have to catch up you know the
policies of 20 years in in six months
why you know much of the economy is
still not working and at the same time
we have this
insane wealth effect and stimulus that's
in demand so uh it's like trying to take
down a fire while pouring gasoline on it
at the same time yep
well so so you mentioned china
um
how
how do you interpret
kind of how very bold they've become
on the world stage and in inside inside
of their own country i mean
i mean now china is the wealthiest
nation on the planet which is kind of
hard to believe but there's more wealth
in china than there is
in any other country
uh and then there's the element of xi
jinping
and whether or not he is as
as invincible as he appears to be
whether there i mean i hear some friends
say there's there there could be
enemies within and then finally what you
know what what are your thoughts on on
on taiwan
it's a lot lots to unpack there sorry
i think that was the plan all along
from the start and
you know basically so after the the end
of the
uh we have the cultural revolution the
gang of four the economies in complete
shackle uh you know you have mass
starvation
uh and this is when when china kind of
walks back from from the points of
maoism with thenxialping start the
special economic zones starts opening up
and and thank you helping ideas when
china is very weak right now so we're
going to keep a low profile uh but the
idea was you know build a low profile so
you can gain strength right it's you
know like playing gold i mean
you assess your position if your
position of weakness you know you have
to play humbly uh and and you know
that's what china did and the dang and
the uh the youngs
and progressively astronaut became more
prosperous and prosperous you saw them
become increasingly uh nationalistic and
saying hey well you know maybe i should
matter right so
it's a national revolutionary thing uh i
think in sieging means mine and really
pretty much i mean
everyone i spoke with in china is
that that that is not just a ccp thing i
mean they kind of view you know
china as a natural leader of the world
you know it's the middle kingdom it's
you know between heaven and earth
everybody around is a barbarian every
other king has to pay tribute to the
emperor of china the the the son of
heaven and and we're just going back
there we're just undoing these
historical anomalies when the barbarians
were able to you know bomb out on the
ports uh and now now is the time to flex
the muscles so xi jinping has been the
guy who flexed the muscles versus the
belt and were initiative and you know
man with more aggressive behavior
towards his neighbor uh but i i think
that was the power alone and in a way i
mean this is how great powers behave i
mean there was nothing
uh
gentle about the rising united states uh
the united states was also involved in
piracy and stealing intellectual
property from the uk
ask about latin americans ask about the
mexicans how they felt about the rise of
the united states or the spanish during
the
the the the cuban wars i mean
a nation that rises will you know try to
impose its will by force uh in the case
of china of course it's
because the country is so big and so
centralized
it's a big shock to the economy and in a
way a much riskier one
in terms of its uh conflict possible
conflict with the us and the fact that
you know china has molded disputes with
pretty much every country around it
whether it's india nehemiah taiwan the
sporty islands uh well with russia they
cannot solve it uh the whole city of
japan is still there so
um
yes it's it is probably the biggest
geopolitical challenge of our time
interesting um
let's uh let let's go back uh to the
well and and here's my here's my other
question about china um
china's just come through an episode
in
call it their their junk bond sector
concentrated in the property er
will will chinese markets
uh
be isolated and insulated from the
global financial system is that going to
remain the case going forward
because it certainly was i think
surprising it wasn't surprising to me
because
i've got friends in china who are like
it's going to be contained
you know by gunpoint but uh
but
do you think that the global
because
2021 is 2020 and 2021 there's going to
be more foreign direct investment into
china than there is into the united
states the numbers are just what they
are
so companies continue to put money into
china
and yet so
do you think their financial system ever
weaves its way into the global financial
system
i mean eventually i think that's that's
their goal but they're very uh
very cautious about it i mean they saw
what happened to uh east asia in in the
90s uh opened up the capital account
they had all these you know frozen money
and then in 1998 then you know
currencies got destroyed the imf had to
walk in so i think that's kind of
the nightmare scenario for china is to
open the week you know also generally
there you know bureaucrats are going to
be bureaucrats but they want to keep
control uh
so especially you know when you're a
marxist bureaucrat uh
is your opportunity to do to remain so
to answer your question the capital
account in china is still not really
open it's still actually mostly closed
uh so that's i think that's the reason
why you don't see contagion uh is
because uh money can move freely in and
out of china uh and also another picture
in china is its extremely high savings
rate and financial regression i mean
consumption as a share of gp is probably
around 40 percent
close to 75 80 in the us right so what
does that mean i mean there's 60 of
household income that flows through the
banking sector or the real estate sector
or whatever but it's not being consumed
cannot move away freely right it's kind
of hard for um you know chinese uh
people to own assets abroad so that
creates this um
huge part of money with which it can
restructure the banking sector uh very
easily without the intervention of
foreigners or the imf and i think that
was always the plan right i think it's
again the chinese leaders leadership has
been very
a cautious study of what happened in
1998 1999 east asia wants to avoid that
so they want to be able to have their
own bubbles and then clean the mess
themselves and again
as long as the the people
who own the assets and the liability
owns it all of them in the same currency
and the same country
matter of transfer you know okay who's
going to get the hit on these evergrande
bond right i mean is it going to be the
the banks the westminster regional
investors
it's something that can be managed
internally and i think that's that's
been the pattern so far
um
and i don't see it uh coming to uh kind
of a global contagion at this point
uh i i i hear your point on uh
yes more money is throwing me to china
and large wars at the at the
bequest of of large investment firms in
the u.s like the black black the golden
statuses giant market you know it's
extremely high state and it's the
wealthiest country on earth with a 60
savings rate if you're an investment
manager
you know you see the big fight of money
you just want in trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars yes yes
um so speaking of trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars uh
let's let's go let's come back to united
states and the tail wagging the dog
so um
you you have said in the past that there
is such a thing as peak passive
and more recently you you flagged six
different indicators that suggest to you
that
that something is bubbling under the
surface that there's tension rising in
in passive investing valuations are
structurally higher
um
when when corrections do occur they're
less they're less frequent they're
they're not as deep the recoveries come
faster the largest index capitalization
stocks keep getting bigger
prices are clearly divorced from
fundamentals
they're also completely disconnected
from economics and economic data i mean
we've seen we've seen you know cars
sales go from 18
million a month
seasonally
adjusted annualized rate to 13.
and
and the consumer discretionary sector
has gone haywire in in the face of this
so um
and and also ceo's
pay and stock-based compensation so so
these are some things that you're
looking at and and what do they tell you
well to me you know the concept that the
preponderance of evidence right this is
kind of how you would use in a in a
criminal jury uh
none of these things are the smoking gun
i mean for each of the the six forces
that you
outline here you can find another
explanation monetary policy would be one
of them uh for a lot of these things
uh or globalization um but then
again there's a common thread with all
of this is that they could all be the
result of the passive hypothesis so
again
you know
it's not a smoking gun like we haven't
found the the dead corpse and the
the guy with that you know the the hand
the bloody the bloody hand in the uh the
dirty knife in the hand but
there's a proponent of it so let me just
walk through uh
the the list so evaluation is
structurally high and constantly rising
so
until uh until spy was launched in 1993
if you look at a long term chart of of
the the p ratio of the s p 500 uh sheila
has done that you can download that on
his ideal website and you just see like
something that just goes up and down you
know i've been the growing twenties done
the depression and you know back up all
the way up in the 70s and it's a
perfectly minivan series which cannot
make sense right it's like well you know
the uh
uh you know sometimes people get over
optimistic they overpay for assets and
they drop take you know this pattern
broke in 1993 which happens to be the
year you know spy the first etf was
launched and of course accelerated in
the past every since 2016 when we've
seen this inflection really i think 2016
means you know the way people say about
bankruptcy how it happened personally
then um i mean i think firstly then well
at once i think that was kind of all at
once moment right so
that's the first one uh corrections are
rarer and recoveries are faster uh again
look at the patterns in terms of the the
the correction so away try you know 50
drop you know market didn't make a new
high i think it's just 2013. uh
you know uh uh the whole market that you
know was very short the powell
powerbear market you know
as soon as powell came out and said okay
so it was over
uh and then even kobe which to me had
the potential of being like a secular
market when you think about impact i
mean
the month it was gone
um
stock prices collected from companies
phenomenal i think this one's so obvious
i don't need to address it you already
mentioned some
some ideas but you look at the
performance of companies no profit even
no sales you see companies more sales
probably like 200 billion market cap wow
this is insane um
the largest stock i perform i think is
another good
good interesting example so one of the
most established anomaly in in stock
market is
you know you could beat them you could
be the indexers by not investing in the
largest stock uh for 70 80 years that
always worked and that's because you
know it's hard to be the top dog right i
mean you top down everybody's shooting
for you you have these economies of
scale you become complacent and you can
think about ibm you think about
exxonmobil
by general electric all the you know
once great companies that have fallen um
and the exact opposite is happening
today right the ones that do the best
are apple and microsoft and they just
keep getting bigger and bigger and uh
and i think some of that is coming from
this demand from passive phones uh the
bigger they get the more they must be
bought uh regardless of other multiples
i mean you look at you know the multiple
of on microsoft's amaze like
how big are they going to be
do they need to be in order to justify
this going forward well it doesn't
matter because it's not about the future
earnings of microsoft i mean it's more
money than university vehicles
uh
and then yeah the last one that we
mentioned is ceo pay and submit
compensation i think that's that's one
that's that's forgotten and that's
almost conspirational out here but
passive is very nice if you're a ceo you
know i mean because shareholders are
paying the but uh you know you have to
report your board and you have to like
do the things you don't want to do but
if it's just an index fund that just you
know either doesn't vote or they voted
just like for the proxy advice which is
you know i mean the the proxy that's
another segment of the industry that's
completely ridiculous well that means
you kind of have a free year i mean a
passive investor that's the dream like
if you're a you know a startup like you
know i have found this oh my god my vc
wants he's so bad oh no he's just gonna
give me the money let me do what i want
oh well i'm you know yeah maybe i'm
gonna get that private jet yeah that
works hard maybe i'm gonna get that you
know that multi-million dollar package
because no one's going to tell me
anything and you see that's only a big
tech firm when you know ceo pay at
mostly stock bases increase and also the
amount of money that they pay to their
employees in stock because they know
that there is a sceptic demand
for for their shares right they know
that the money is thrown into these
passive vehicles every month they know
that because of a larger stock in the
index they must be bought so they can
issue in some some big tech companies
issue about 10 of their float every year
in stock based compensation
in a normal world they would have to pay
cash now cash is annoying because you
can't clean cash or you go to jail
but
you can prick you can print your shares
and and then you know and if people can
sell it you've effectively discovered
the printing press and yet the same
exact companies that you've just
mentioned are also the the biggest
dinosaurs the hugest beasts inside of
the share buyback machine
at the same time they kind of need to
right i mean because otherwise people
would notice like you know if your
facebook is like you issue so many many
shares
you know your phone's gonna grow so what
you're gonna do because your business is
so profitable because you are a monopoly
uh while you use some of that you do buy
back but effectively that's that's
really taking money from shareholders to
give it to insider in a very convoluted
way with a tax advantage well you can
you can borrow debt to do it i mean
yes
and i mean i don't think this is an
outcome that's socially optimal in any
way i mean it does not serve the benefit
of society at large because you lose on
the tax basis uh you make society more
unequal
and also you i would argue you'll be
part of shareholders i mean because um
you know instead of uh
um you know your
the share count remains the same but the
cash balance keeps going down because
you constantly need to uh buy back your
shares to upset the shares that you give
them yourself so it's pretty much the
same thing as really
i mean if you think about it same thing
as taking money at the end of the day
from the cash account and giving it to
yourself just use that converted loop
to make it okay
well on that happy note i've got a few
last uh last burning questions so i i
kind of i understood the english
i understood the french and i understood
the italian
um
i'm sorry but why do you speak
indonesian i
i don't think i could have a
conversation at this point
anymore
okay i couldn't either that's the good
news
yeah no one can call me on this one no
but back in france when i was studying
uh let's say
if you wanted to work for the ministers
of the the foreign affairs ministry you
had to speak a uh
a weird name
oriental that's a very called an
oriental language uh
and um you know i i did in singapore
which is very close to indonesia and
indonesia has the peculiarity of being
this the simplest indonesian is the
simplest language in the world right
they had all these these
thousands of islands who spoke different
languages they standardized everything
and they came up with this language it's
extremely simple and even if you're not
you know you can learn it in a couple
months uh
and get by with so that that was back
when i thought i was going to work for
that uh
in the french public service uh i
already always wanted to kind of you
know live abroad and i thought that was
the fastest way to achieve that and it's
it's a fun language it's a beautiful
country
uh
and um
generally i think it's you know learning
languages really helps
see the world different way well um and
thank you i i was just it was just a
moment of curiosity on my part i said
that that that that how does that fit
with that um
so
obviously you you uh you're in
i call them in the weeds kind of a guy i
mean you're you're you're formulaic you
think in in calculus and um and and so
you actually get together
occasionally and and go on hikes with a
few people kind of like you like like
like brent johnson and and mike green
and alex garevich
i'm curious to know when when you guys
are hiking
what are you talking about
and by the way wait wait why is mike
green always tweeting out these weird
pictures of food and what's this keto
things i'm just i got to know what what
are you guys talking about hiking up the
hill
mike talks a lot about his keto diet
uh
no i know he does tweet a lot about it
yes yes yes uh no actually i think it
was
mike i think came up with the idea got
got a bunch of uh
kind of investors or
economists or global macro or hedge fund
managers in the case of alex together
and say hello let's meet let's talk
about you know the economy where we see
things going but let's do that in a uh
kind of friendly setting and at the time
you know you want to be back in shape
which you know i think why
he went the hike and i don't know if
you've been to marin but you get some
pretty good hills there i mean it's
stunning it's just so beautiful i mean
i've lived here for 12 years and still i
cannot believe my eyes when i want to
climb up hockey or whatever and just see
that it's it's really wonderful so
there's a you know
let's see let's be let's get smart and
and let's uh let's be in good shape
which which mike is on a fantastic uh
fantastic job at uh now i mean i'm i'm
the youngest guy in the group but um you
know very often now they i mean i used
to be the first at the top of the hill
now i struggle to catch up with them and
you know it's just a
you know group of friends meeting we get
beers after that uh brent johnson is a i
mean his personality real life
personality is just as nice as
especially on twitter and he's just one
of the nicest guys i've met the funniest
guy so i
i mean
i'm kind of a young guy there so i i
tend to listen more than i speak
uh
and i'm i'm really fortunate to to have
met these guys and i mean i've learned
so much from them i mean it's one of the
beauty and i know you're very active on
twitter i think it's one of the ways i
think that the industry has changed for
the better is
um you know it's much easier to make
connections with people if you have
something smart to say people will
eventually pick it up you can get into
conversation with people you would have
never you know i would have never
hoped to speak with you you know 10
years ago so and and yet here we are so
there is i mean we spent a lot of time
you know talking about the ideals of big
tech which which i i share with it but
there is also a positive aspect if
you're looking for good content on
youtube like this channel you put out if
you want to have conversation with more
people you can do that you no longer
need to be you know a cfa goldman sachs
hey excuse the world so it it's it's
flattened the game and i hope we can i
hope we can get rid of the negative
effect of big tech on society but also
keep this kind of
uh free flow of idea and demonstration
of finance well i i i completely agree
uh i mean it's it's opened up a world to
me to see how people
react to
my twitter it's it's a very gratifying
not the ones in the middle of the night
i can deal without them but um so i've
got i've got one final question here so
you're you're out out towards the wine
country
and you but you're a frenchman
uh living in california so i've got to
ask when it comes to the important
things in life which are
wine and cheese
uh
which is better french or california
ah cheese i don't think there should be
a debate here okay
no no it's true i mean even in the
process like you know you probably use
low milk in the us i mean you can get
decent cheese in california but at the
variety of uh
english charles de gaulle had this um it
was being frustrated with the french one
time and said how can you rule a country
with 500 different kind of cheeses um
which spoke to truth that one the fact
that the french are grumpy and unruly
and two that they make really delicious
cheese uh so i don't think there should
be a debate there uh on the one i mean
it's i i i this one's a matter of taste
i mean obviously you have fantastic ones
coming up now past sonoma oregon uh
washington i mean for me a lot of them
tasted a little bit too sweet i'm you
know i'm from burgundy so i like the you
know the pinots but
i am
my taste buds kind of got used to it now
i like the chardonnays here so i mean
with wines i think you know
you know it there's nothing that's
better or worse it's just whatever you
like whatever feels better what you eat
the company you're in i mean you know i
think also people take these things a
little too seriously i mean you know one
just you know something to be enjoyed
with a good meal with friends it's not
something to showcase social status or
you know you i don't want to talk for
like you know 15 minutes about you know
the color i don't want it i want to
enjoy it and and california one is you
know very enjoyable well that was spoken
like a true frenchman absolutely and we
should and you're right uh i hope one
day we can have a glass of wine in
person it would be great to meet you on
some future and i love italian wine by
the way so you're i mean you're the ones
who came up with it uh so that this is a
gift of the romans the goals so
uh as many things the french told what
the italians did and pretend it was
ours actually true even though the
medici sent
away
um
the second biggest wine family into
exile into burgundy years ago um
but that's a different story for a
different day uh i visit i want to thank
you for all of the time that you've
spent and i hope to um you know make me
you know what maybe one day i'll sit you
and mike green down together and the
three of us can can finally figure out
uh the secret to to passive and whether
or not we're ever going to see peak
passive or whether we're going to get to
that 100 percent mark and then the world
will end but i really really appreciate
your time and i wish you the best and
look forward to doing this again
sometime
thank you danielle thank you very much
have a great day you too take care
well you may think that the
the idea of passive investing or
exchange traded funds or the way your
401k
automatically grabs a portion of your
paycheck uh before you get paid you may
think that it's a really boring issue
but when you consider that it's gone
from a tiny slice of the stock market to
now where it dominates the stock market
understanding passive investing is
really important because that's possibly
one of the largest bubbles that we've
ever seen in in u.s stock market history
and again
most american workers are kind of blind
to the role that it's playing in
planning out their retirement so if you
enjoyed that discussion with vincent i i
suggest that you go back i've done two
interviews with mike green so go back
and and watch those as well because i
think understanding passive investing
and understanding the etfs you just
happen to own in your 401k is going to
be more and more critical as a factor of
time and uh and
for now i will i will say goodbye and
look forward to the next time that you
are back with me on down the middle
thanks take care
[Music]
you